at 6 00 a.m every morning i had to get
on a city bus
and ride for an hour sometimes more just
to get to school
and i was willing to do that because i
was willing to do whatever it took for
me to go to college
i set my sights high
i decided i was going to princeton
but i quickly realized that for me
a kid like me
getting into princeton wasn't just going
to happen on its own
see i went to a great school but at my
school we had so many kids so few
guidance counselors they were dealing
with hundreds of students
so they didn't always have much time to
help me personally
get my applications together plus
i knew i couldn't afford
to go on a bunch of college visits
i couldn't hire a personal tutor i
couldn't enroll in sat prep classes we
didn't have the money
and then get this
some of my teachers straight up told me
that i was setting my sights too high
they told me i was never going to get
into a school like princeton
and i still hear that doubt ringing in
my head
so it was clear to me
that nobody was gonna take my hand
and lead me to where i needed to go
instead it was going to be up to me to
reach my goal
i would have to chart my own course
there are those of us that are born with
this sort of thing in us you know i
write about it in my book because i had
to reflect on sort of how did i get here
you know what were the things in my life
that made the difference
and some of it was that i was
temporarily temperamentally always that
kid always that i'll show you you know
you give me a challenge
i'll prove you wrong you know uh so
people are born with the temperament
that and and that's that internal hunger
that i'm that i'm talking about you know
and that imagine having a girl like that
somewhere in the world who doesn't get
to exercise that where that feeling that
that temperament isn't nurtured
for me it was nurtured and it started
simply with
parents who believed in my voice
and i share that with people because my
parents weren't wealthy you know they
were not well connected they didn't go
to college themselves we were not
we we were a poor family
um but what they gave me was a sense of
belief that my voice the words that came
out of my mouth were clever
and interesting and they were interested
in it
so when you start with a foundation
where you're telling a kid
very early on that they are valuable
that those words in and of themselves
can make a difference it isn't magic it
isn't money it isn't resources and
that's what you know some families miss
you know there are families who believe
that if i can't give my kids stuff
then i should just be quiet and let them
be well now the truth is is that
teaching a girl teaching an individual
early on how to use their voice and that
their voice matters allows them to then
be advocates for themselves as they go
along are you going to throw up your
hands and say that progress
will never come are you going to get
angry and lash out
are you going to turn inward
and just give in to despair and
frustration
or are you going to take a deep breath
straighten your shoulders lift up your
head and do what barack obama has always
done as he says when they go low
i go high
that's the choice
barack and i have made that's what has
kept us sane over the years we simply do
not allow space in our hearts minds or
souls for darkness
instead
we choose faith
faith in ourselves in the power of hard
work faith in our god
whose overwhelming love sustains us
every single day that's what we choose
we choose love
our love for our children
our commitment to leaving them a better
world our love for our country which has
given us so many blessings and
advantages
our love for our fellow citizens parents
working hard to support their kids
men and women in uniform who risk
everything to keep us safe
young people from the toughest
backgrounds who never stop believing in
their dreams young people like so many
of you
that's what we choose
and we choose excellence
we choose to tune out all the noise and
strive for excellence in everything we
do no cutting corners no taking
shortcuts no whining we a kid will
believe you know a day like we had in
vietnam
you can wake up either feeling changed
or you can feel like did that happen
and then if it if nothing good ever
comes after that it reinforces the
disappointment that they feel on an
ongoing basis it's like yeah they came
they saw the cameras were here the
lights were on but
weeks went by and you know i never heard
from them again
and that's
that we try to avoid when we work with
kids
so when i was first lady whenever we had
a powerful interaction with a group of
kids
whether it was islington whether it was
in vietnam whether it's in cambodia
it couldn't just be that moment we had
to we made sure that we followed up at
least two or three or four there's only
so much i can do with this big platform
but you guys as leaders you know that
consistent return
to them
will be the thing that they remember
it's not the first visit it's the second
and the third and the fifth visit
so because that's the kind of repetition
that you need with children with your
own children you know as you're teaching
them anything it's they take it in the
more you repeating repeated parenting is
about repetition
nope can't do it
still can't
nope
the answer is still no
and probably around the 10th maybe the
100th time they'll be like i guess it's
not but the same thing is true with the
positive reinforcement that you have in
the life of a child and
quite frankly that's true for any issue
that you're taking on
it's that once you take it on
then do it
show up for the communities that you're
serving
um because so many of the communities
that we all work in have been
disappointed and they're used to that
let down they're used to that sort of
one one one hit and then we're on think
about one of my heroines marion wright
edelman
class of 1960
working
as a young civil rights lawyer down in
mississippi
attorneys in judges chambers refused to
shake her hand
the sheriff locked the doors against her
when she came to visit her clients in
jail
she was always careful to leave the door
open when she started her car in the
morning
that way if somebody planted a car bomb
she had
a chance of being injured rather than
killed
but through it all she continued to
represent her clients she continued to
resist unjust laws with every fiber of
her being
then there's janet bragg class of 1925
who was determined to be a pilot
when she was barred from flying out of
segregated airports
she worked with her flying school
classmates and instructors to build
their own airfield
when she was rejected from the women air
force service pilots because of a race
she enrolled in a civilian training
program instead when she completed her
training
but an instructor unfairly prevented her
from receiving her license she picked up
and moved to chicago passed the exam and
became the first african-american woman
to earn a commercial pilot's license
[Applause]
of her experiences she said
there was so many things they said women
couldn't do
and blacks couldn't do
every defeat to me was a challenge
for six generations
that is what spelman women have done
they have seen every defeat
as a challenge
now did they have moments of doubt
anxiety and fear
did they have moments of despair
when they thought about giving up or
giving in
of course they did
we all do
and i am no exception when i uh
i got to college that that happened to
me
during my very first semester
i took a class on greek mythology yes
greek mythology that was way over my
head
i found myself sitting in a
lecture hall full of juniors and seniors
how did i get there struggling just to
keep up and by the time i took the
midterm exam all i could muster was a c
and it was the very first c i'd ever
gotten and i was devastated
but instead of wilting
i found a way to fight through it i
poured my heart and soul into a paper i
spent a lot of time talking to the
professors before and after class
and in the end i ended up getting a good
grade in that class but what i learned
was
far more important than that letter
grade from that experience what i
learned was that
when something doesn't go your way
you just gotta adjust
you've got to
dig deep and work like crazy
and that's when you'll find out what
you're really made of during those hard
times
but you can only
do that if you're willing to put
yourself in a position where you might
fail
and that's why so often failure is the
key to success for so many great people
take steve jobs who was fired from apple
early in his career
and now his ipods and ipads and iphones
have revolutionized the entire world
oprah
was demoted from her first job as a news
anchor
now she doesn't even need a last name
and then there's this guy barack obama
who lost
[Music]
[Applause]
i could take up a whole afternoon
talking about his failures but
he lost his first race for congress
and now
he gets to call himself my husband when
we drop
our guards
and we let ourselves become vulnerable
and
that vulnerability allows us to share
our true stories with each other not you
know not the
the stuff on the surface but
the things that really connect us like
how we were raised
the values that we learned around the
dinner table
the people who impacted us in our lives
the things that made us scared that you
know the things that gave us courage um
that when we share that truth
we can see ourselves in each other a
little bit better no matter no matter
what right um
you know
your dad is someone that i've
you take the politics out of it
and i had an opportunity to sit by your
father
at funerals the highs and the lows and
we shared stories about our kids and
about our parents
our values are the same we disagree on
policy
but we don't disagree on humanity we
don't disagree about love and compassion
i think that's true for all of us it's
just that
we get lost in in our fear
of what's different
so yeah we we've gotta you know we gotta
work on that but i think that this
generation coming up
you know i think they know more than we
did each generation knows a little bit
more you know while one can argue that
social media is problematic it's also
opening young people up to
new ideas to each other to other parts
of the world
my hope is that they will be more
open-minded and more secure in who they
are so that they can welcome other
people's stories into the mix but
it has to begin with us being willing to
be vulnerable and share who we really
are with our neighbors so that we're not
strangers to each other and that way we
don't we can't let somebody else from
the outside tear us apart because we
know each other right i know you i've
seen you we broke bread together you
know i may not agree with you but i like
you you are my neighbor
that takes work and commitment other
people told me that i might not be able
to
to do well in school
for whatever reason i was always a good
student i worked hard but i thought
there was some magic
that happened
that made you really you know i didn't
know that it was just plain old hard
work
so there were periods of doubt for sure
i think we all i have doubts today
doubts don't go away um you just learn
how to
deal with them you you start knowing
yourself and you become more confident
the more successes you have the more
chances you take uh the
you don't let the the failures or the
stumbles define you
you know everybody falls every now and
then some people fall a lot
and what i realized is that we have long
lives if we're healthy and
uh we do what we're supposed to do
i'm 47 years old
so think about it whatever mistake i
made when i was 13
who cares
so think about life as a long trajectory
but at the same time
you don't want to make huge mistakes
because when you're young
making big big mistakes can last forever
right
so you want to choose wisely
but the stumbles the lessons learned
that's part of life that makes you grow
but i i came to know that i didn't know
that when i was your age i thought every
every mistake was the end of the world
i'll never be able i'll never get into
school i'll never be you know of course
we all feel that way
um but just continue to work put the put
the effort in and i think
that has been
some of what's helped me being first
lady
first first of all is knowing who you
are and being confident in yourself
because they'll be
clear as to what do you say pushing
beyond other people's labels of you
right that's a big part that's what we
do to each other all the time we don't
even know each other and we already
determined from one glance meeting one
line one word one phrase this is who you
are
so you have to know who you are
before that
and you and you live that reality and
you keep living it out no matter what
and if you're a good have good character
and and good intentions
that that ultimately shines through uh
but in the end it's hard work
and
i like to work hard and i'd i'd like to
do good things
um and you practice that now
and believe it or not i didn't know it
it prepared me to be the first lady of
united states i didn't know i guess i'm
doing okay but you know what
every day we just get up and keep doing
what we think is the right thing i
didn't find my passion until long after
college
heck until after law school i mean the
truth is i spent still spent way too
much of my time at princeton
continuing to chase grades and check
boxes and climb higher and higher i went
on to law school i did the same thing
by the time i was in my mid-20s i had
everything i was told i should want
fancy job at a prestigious law firm a
big office a nice paycheck
but
on the inside
something was missing
and so
after a few
knocks i finally asked myself some big
questions simple questions
what did i want out of my life
what makes me happy
what do i care about
yeah simple questions that i never
bothered to ask too busy checking boxes
and soon i realized that what i
really wanted
was pretty simple
i wanted to give back to the people
around me to the world around me i
wanted to live my life by the principle
that to whom much is given much is
expected
so
for me
that led me to quit that fancy job
and since then i've dedicated my life to
giving back i've worked to train young
people for
careers in public service i've started
community outreach programs at a college
in a hospital and today is first lady
i'm working to honor our nation's
military families and help our children
grow up healthy
but as i look back
i wish i'd
asked myself what i really wanted when i
was sitting right where you are
so graduates my message to all of you
today is this
do not waste a minute living someone
else's dream
each of us has unique gifts
but it takes
a lot of work
a lot of real work to discover what
brings you joy just doesn't happen it
requires you spending your some time and
you won't find
what you love simply by checking boxes
or padding your gpa you won't figure it
out only by listening to your guidance
counselor your friends or even your
parents
you can only find your passion by
looking inside yourself what's the best
advice do you think you've given your
daughters oh gosh i give them so much
advice they're so sick of me
you know now that they're in college i
have these texting did i ever did i tell
you to remember little things like you
are eating some green things aren't you
um but what is the thing that over the
years was a running theme in your house
that you said over and over you know
what i tell them is what i continue to
tell themselves is that
they have to walk their own walk
you know they they cannot define
themselves by looking at each other or
looking at me or their dad they have to
take the time to get to know themselves
give themselves a moment to figure out
who they want to be in the world not who
they think i want them to be not what
the rest of the world says about them
but to really think about how they want
to shape their lives and how they want
to move in this world
so i don't want them measuring
themselves by external influences and
for young girls that is hard to do oh
you know that is a very hard thing to do
and everybody should understand that as
a responsibility it's instagram culture
oh it it drives me crazy it was hard
when it was hard with just cable tv when
you're watching all the images and in in
music videos it's i don't know
exponentially difficult with with social
media when you're comparing yourself to
everybody on social media so i
constantly have to remind them
that they have to live in their own skin
and that takes time too and i try to
make sure they understand that that
that unfolding of understanding who you
are
it it is a journey of becoming you don't
know it all in your 20s
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free check out my
training right here below or if you want
some more affirmations from marissa peer
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there